In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadium for July 11 on which we commemorate the Holy Great
martyr, Elfamiya, the All-Famed.
On the 11th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy and Great martyr, Elfamiya,
who confirmed the confession of faith of the 630 God-bearing fathers gathered in Calcedon.
For the 4th Ecumenical Council.
At the 4th Holy Ecumenical Council, convoked by the devout Emperor Marcian and Empress
Polkheria, in Calcedon, in the vast Basilica of Saint Elfamiya, the 630 fathers undertook
to refute the heretical opinions of Archimandrite utiches, which were supported by deoscorous archbishop
of Alexandria.
In order to settle their differences by a decision that had come from God, the Holy
Patriarch Anatolios suggested that each of the two parties write a volume containing their
respective professions of faith, and that the two documents be placed in the reliquary
containing the body of Saint Elfamiya.
The two scrolls in which were written the definitions of the faith concerning the person of Christ,
were then placed on the saint's chest, and after having sealed the casket, the fathers
fell to prayer.
After eight days, they all went to the martyrium, and opening the reliquary discovered with
wonder that the saint was clutching the orthodox scroll in her hands as though she wanted
to press it into her heart.
While the heretics scroll lay at her feet.
Before this amazing demonstration of truth, the orthodox gave thanks to God, and the heretics
booed by the crowd were covered with shame.
Many other miracles were wrought by Saint Elfamiya.
During a Persian invasion, the barbarians, having invaded Calcedon, attempted to destroy
the precious relics by fire.
But they remained intact, and fresh blood flowed from one of the holes the Persians had made
in the reliquary.
This miracle was repeated from time to time, procuring many healings for the faithful who
came to gather the blood of Saint Elfamiya.
But more frequently, her tomb exhaled a delicate perfume, testifying to the favor that the
saint had with God.
To protect the precious relics from further profanation, they were transferred to Constantinople,
where they were placed in the church of Saint Elfamiya near the Hippodrome.
Throne into the sea during the persecution by Constantin Copronimos, the church being turned
into an armament's store, the relics came ashore on the coast of Lemnos, and were found
by fishermen.
Discovered during the reign of Empress Irene, they were solemnly translated to the capital
in the year 796, where they continued to work miracles.
After having undergone many other vicissitudes, they are venerated today in the church of
the Ecumenical Patriarchate in the Fennar.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.